let's talk now about that reelection
this is an interesting story that I want
to be careful about because when I talk
about this I don't want to inadvertently
make anybody think that maybe they don't
need to go out and vote in November
everybody needs to go out and vote in
November but it's an interesting story
nonetheless Donald Trump is the most
unpopular president as of January 1 of
their reelection year to seek reelection
dating back all the way 44 years to
Gerald Ford seeking re-election in 1976
and Donald Trump's still might win
despite that according to 538 on January
1st just a few days ago Donald Trump's
approval rating was forty two point six
percent this might now be lower because
of the Iran stuff or it might be higher
we don't really know but that was the
number as of January 1st only Gerald
Ford had a lower approval rating On
January 1 of an election year of
reelection year who was polling thirty
nine point three percent on January 1st
of 1976 now my memory when I was
starting to research this yesterday was
that George W Bush was very unpopular
when running for re-election and indeed
he was at forty eight point nine percent
approval but that was higher than Barack
Obama at forty five point seven percent
Barack Obama winning re-election very
easily in 2012 so there's a few
important messages here the most
important one is if George W Bush was
reelected with a forty eight point nine
percent approval on January 1 of his
reelection year if Barack Obama was
re-elected with forty five point seven
percent approval on January one of his
re-election year Trump can be reelected
at forty two point six percent
especially in this hyper partisan
environment where Trump is likely to
lose the popular vote because of big
deficits and large blue states like
California and New York but to eke out
wins in those few key states that handed
him the electoral college victory in
2016 so when you see this it's
interesting we don't know how Trump's
approval will will move between now and
Election Day it means nothing about
whether we need to get out and vote the
answer is yes we do the other thing to
remember is that November approval need
not
anything like January 1st approval and
in fact if you look at the last 11
presidents who ran for re-election of
the eleven six saw their approval go
down between January 1st and the
election five saw their approval go up
between January 1st and the election so
for Trump this means to get out of the
danger zone he needs to try to get his
approval closer to 50% for us this means
assume nothing vote work every state
consider no state safe I mean we know
California Massachusetts New York we
know that they're going blue but work
the election work every state Trump was
one of the most disliked and unpopular
candidates that ran right I mean
remember before he was elected he was
extremely unpopular within the
Republican primary and he's still won we
are fighting some of the most malignant
ly ignorant people in the country to try
to remove this guy incumbency is a
powerful thing we need to fight it on
all fronts public activism
get-out-the-vote we've got to be
fighting voter suppression that is
happening in many states and we are
trying to fight it in many of those
states fight gerrymandering fight the
foreign influence which is of course
going to be an issue once again and to
put sort of like a final point on this
despite Gerald Ford's approval rating of
only 39% back in 1976 he lost the
popular vote by only a million and a
half votes that's about half of the
margin that Trump lost by in 2016
put another way as unpopular as Gerald
Ford was in 1976 Trump lost the popular
vote by twice as much in 2016 and still
won the electoral college so the
takeaway is don't do anything that would
be influenced by thinking that it's in
the back I still believe that it is more
than plausible that Donald Trump gets
himself reelected sometimes people you
know whenever I let's actually address
that because we were going to have a
long election cycle here of this I I've
said many times I am against Donald
Trump I think there's
a great chance that Donald Trump is
defeated but I think it's perfectly
plausible and in some cases if certain
things go a certain way even likely that
Donald Trump gets himself reelected and
when I say that I'll get emails from
people in the audience who say David
you're being really demoralizing by
saying you think Donald Trump could get
reelected I'm being realistic with you
and if anything when you hear me say
that it shouldn't demoralize you it
should make you commit to voting and to
getting out the vote
the idea that stating that the president
could realistically get himself
reelected is demoralizing is the
absolute wrong interpretation the
interpretation should be half the
country doesn't vote let's go out and
get people voting so that we can win
this thing let's go to a break
afterwards a CNBC put up the wrong
pictures of Andrew yang and Tulsi
Gabbard in a recent segment I want to
talk with you about whether it is
ignorant or malice and we will of course
raise hanlin's raiser always a great
quote when we talk about ignorant versus
malice your voicemails and many other
things coming up